Hello everyone, my
name is Kaylee Bressler
and I'm an academic
medicine scholar.
I'm going to be giving
you the lecture on
hemostasis this year
thanks to Dr. Petku.
So here are our
learning objectives.
The first one is to describe
the steps that occur
in primary and secondary
hemostasis. Then we're going
to differentiate between
the intrinsic, extrinsic,
and common pathways of
the coagulation cascade.
Then we will identify
mechanisms of anticoagulation
that prevent
hypercoagulability states.
We will describe
fibrinolysis as the
final step in hemostasis
and then apply
these principles to
clinical scenarios.
So before we get started,
I just want you to take a
second and think about why
hemostasis is important, what
it is, why do we need to
know about it, and how it's
going to help us when we are
physicians in the future.
Great, so hemostasis is a
process in which bleeding
is stopped. So this is
important when there are
penetrating injuries
resulting in substantial blood
loss and also when you
get a paper cut. One of
the biggest ways that
hemostasis is relevant to us
as future physicians is
the way in which it can be
affected by drugs. So
there's warfarin, heparin,
anoxaparin, all of these
are highly prescribed
drugs and they are
anticoagulants. So these are going
to prevent hemostasis
from functioning correctly
and put patients at an
increased risk for bleeds.
So the point of this lecture
today is to go through
the entire process of
stopping a bleed, which is
hemostasis. We will discuss the
different steps involved and
the feedback mechanisms and
make sure that that allow
us to make sure that we're
not clotting too much.
And then at the end, I've
included information about
different disorders about
hemostasis and how drugs will
affect this process. But you
will also have additional
lectures that go into much
more detail about this,
especially the mechanisms
of actions of those drugs.
So first, we're just
going to outline the
major steps of hemostasis,
and then we're going
to go into each of
these into more details.
So first, there is an injury
to the endothelium. This
can be either internally,
like a plaque breaks off
from somewhere and damages
the blood vessel, or it can
be external from an injury
occurring outside the body.
Then we move into primary
hemostasis, and then we
have secondary hemostasis,
which consists of two
different pathways, the
intrinsic and extrinsic
pathway. These come together
into the common pathway.
These are what consists
of clotting factors, so
the secondary hemostasis
is also commonly referred
to as the coagulation
cascade. Lastly, we have
fibrinolysis, which is the
process of getting rid of
the clot when the endothelium
has been repaired.
Additionally, we're
going to talk about those
feedback mechanisms
that keep this in check.
So first, we're going
to talk about the
normal endothelium. So
as you guys all know,
it's a single layer of cells
that makes up the wall of
the blood vessel. And under
normal conditions, when
there's no injury, it has
many properties that make it
antithrombotic. So there are
different effector molecules
that are released from the
endothelium. Some of these
are nitric oxide, prostacyclin,
and diphosphatases.
These prevent platelets
from sticking to the vessel
wall and just allow them
to pass through smoothly.
There are also membrane
-bound molecules
present on the
endothelium that inhibit
clotting factors
from being activated.
Heparin-like molecules
bind antithrombin-3.
There is thrombomodulin,
which binds thrombin
and protein C. Both
of these lead to
inactivation of specific
clotting factors.
The endothelium also
releases tissue factor
pathway inhibitor,
which does the same as
those. They inactivate
different factors.
And then lastly, there's
TPA, which we know as a
drug mostly, but it's also
commonly found in the body.
It's released from the
endothelium, which initiates
fibrinolysis in degradation
of fibrin that would
stabilize a clot. So under
normal conditions, your
body just wants blood to
flow smoothly and they're
not trying to stop the
platelets or make a plug.
But then when we have an
injury, that's when the
process of hemostasis
begins. So that injury to the
endothelium then exposes
the subendothelial collagen
that's exposed before.
That's kind of the orange
underneath the blue. So
the blue cells are your
endothelium, and then underneath
you have the collagen.
So the damaged cells
then release a substance
called endothelin. That
causes vasoconstriction.
That causes the
bloodstream to flow down,
the blood to flow slow
down so that the clot
can form. The platelets
slow down. There's more
chance for them to
release different factors.
The exposed collagen binds
von Willebrand factor.
This is a protein that
promotes platelet adhesion.
It can come from a few
different places. It's in
the plasma, and then it
is released from alpha
granules from within
platelets, and then also
weibol piloti bodies that
are found in endothelial
cells. So it is important
to know where it's
coming from in the specific
granule, so definitely
know that alpha granule
in the weibol piloti
bodies. So once that von
Willebrand factor has bound
to the exposed collagen,
the next step is going
to be platelet adhesion. So
platelets have a receptor
on their membrane called
GP1B receptor and that
is what is going to bind to
the von Willebrand factor.
So that's why this
vasoconstriction is important.
It slows down the blood
so that these receptors
have a chance to bind to
the von Willebrand factor.
Next is activation.
Once the platelets have
bound, they change
shape and they release
more mediators to
advance forming the clot.
There are two specific
granules within platelets
that you need to know.
We talked about the alpha
granules secreting von
Willebrand factor. It also
secretes many other factors
that help with clotting.
They're listed here for you
to review, but I underlined
the important ones. Von
Willebrand factor is
really the most important
one for the alpha granule.
And then the dense
granule secretes ADP
and calcium, which
are two important
molecules that help to
advance the process.
Calcium is needed in
secondary hemostasis, so we
will come back to this
one later on. But ADP is
released and it binds to a
different receptor that is
present on platelets. This
is the P2Y12 receptor.
When this binding
happens, it triggers
the platelet to then
expose an additional
receptor, which is
the GP2B3A receptor.
And this is important
for the next step.
And then additionally,
there's also thromboxin A2
that's released. This is,
again, helping with the
vasoconstriction of
slowing the blood down so
that all the platelets can
bind and form this clot.
All right, so next
we have aggregation.
so this is that newly
exposed receptor the gp2b3a
it will now bind fibrinogen
so this helps even more
for the platelets to aggregate
and it's a more secure
connection between the
platelets platelets have
multiple of these receptors
so you can can see in this
photo that they're kind
of connecting to each
other to help them create
this stable fibrin mesh so
this is the last step in
the primary hemostasis and
this is what helps form
that initial platelet plug.
So we're going to pause really
quick to answer a question.
Which of the following has the
correct receptor
and ligand pair?
If you need more time you
can go ahead and pause
the video but we're going
to go over the answer.
So the correct answer is
GP2B3A receptor binds to
fibrinogen. So you want to
be careful and distinguish
this from fibrin, so it's
specifically binding fibrinogen.
The next step we'll go
over how we get to fibrin.
The GP1B receptor is
what binds the von
Willebrand factor, and
then the P2Y12 receptor
binds ADP that's
released from platelets.
All right, so now we're
going to move on to secondary
hemostasis. This is also
known as the coagulation
cascade. I know it looks
a little intimidating
this is just an overview
of the entire system. The
most important thing to
keep in mind is that the
point of this is to stabilize
the platelet plug so
that we are the end result
is that we're converting
fibrinogen to fibrin
which is a more stable
molecule. So that's really
the entire point of this
entire cascade is to get
from fibrinogen to fibrin.
So first we have the intrinsic
pathway. The important
things to know for each
pathway is going to be
how it is triggered, the
specific differentiating
factors that are involved,
and then the corresponding
lab tests that will be
useful when you guys
go on to rotations and
then also for your boards.
So the intrinsic pathway
is triggered when there is
damage inside the vessel to
the endothelium. So it does
not result in blood loss.
So think intrinsic internal.
So this can also happen
when there are specific
negatively charged
substances that trigger
the activation of that
first factor, which
is factor 12. So some
of those are collagen,
calycrein, and kininogen.
Just trying to remember
collagen. So if you
think of that endothelial
wall breaking, right
underneath it is collagen.
And when that's exposed,
it's going to activate
this first factor.
So the important factors
to remember for this are
factor 12, factor 11, factor
9, and factor 8. So if
you just kind of go down
the pathway and exclude
10, those first four are
what we're looking at here.
And then it's called
a cascade because once
the first one's
activated, it goes on to
activate the next and
the next and so on.
And then the important
lab test that we're
going to talk about here
is the APTT, which stands
for activated partial
thromboplastin time.
These are lab results
that you'll get back if
you think someone has
a bleeding disorder.
You'll test for a lot
of these blood markers.
So normal for this one
is 25 to 40 seconds.
So if it's increased,
it's higher than 40. That
means there's a problem
with this part of the
cascade, and you want to
look at these clotting
factors. This is also
used to monitor heparin
therapy since its
effects are on thrombin,
which you can see here
on the side, is needed to
activate factor VIII,
and then also factor Xa.
Next, we have the
extrinsic pathway.
So this one is triggered
when there is an external
trauma that results in
injury to the vessel
wall and you have blood
loss after that. So think
extrinsic external
injury. So you're damaging
the entire vessel wall,
not just the endothelium.
So factor two is found in
the deeper layers of the
vessel wall. So that's also
helpful to have you think
about external because
that's what's going to be
exposed when this kind of
damage occurs. It's going to
be the muscle cells in
the fibroblast, which is a
much deeper injury. The
important factor here, we have
factor 3 and factor 7.
They come together and they
form a complex that is
going to activate factor 10.
The lab value that's used
to monitor this pathway is
APT, which stands for
activated prothrombin time. It
is normally 11 to 15
seconds, so any increase in
this time means there is a
problem with these factors.
And then it is used to
monitor warfarin therapy.
And this is because
factor 7 is a vitamin K
dependent factor produced
by the liver, and
warfarin decreases the
amount of vitamin K
that you have available
to you, so it's going
to decrease the amount
of factor 7 you have.
All right, so we made it
to the common pathway. So
this is the last step of
each pathway results in
activation of factor 10, and
that is the first step in
the common pathway. So both
intrinsic and extrinsic
come together and results
in this final pathway.
So this goes on to activate
thrombin and factor
13, which results in a
stable fibrin mesh that is
cross-linked with each
other. So this is how we get
from that fibrinogen to
the fibrin, and then it
becomes cross-linked, and
it becomes even stronger.
And then we're going to
talk about thrombin for a
minute. So So thrombin has
many roles in hemostasis,
and it also feeds back on
itself. You can see it at
many points in the coagulation
cascade, but it's not
actually made till down
here in the common pathway.
It was also one of those
molecules released from
platelets. So it comes from
a few different places.
It's important to know
that it has a role in the
formation of the clot, but
it's also important to remember
that on a healthy endothelium,
it has anticoagulant
effects together with
protein C. So we're going to
go over that again, but
just know that depending on
whether the endothelium is
healthy or damaged, there's
always going to be thrombin
and its role changes.
And then we also can see
how important that calcium
was that was released upon
platelet activation and
primary hemostasis it's
necessary in many steps in this
coagulation cascade so
that is why calcium is a
really important activator
that is released by platelets
and then finally the platelets
are going to contract
and leave the clot and the
fiber mesh comes closer
together and this is what
brings those edges of
the vessel wall closer
together and heals that injury
all right I know that was
a lot you guys can go back
through and look at it remember
to just really remember
why each pathway is triggered
the different factors
involved and then those
lab tests those are the
three main important things
so we're going to go over
this question a young girl
falls and scrapes her knee
after the platelet plug is
formed what pathway will
be activated next to stabilize
the platelet plug all
right if you need more
time go ahead and pause it?
So the correct answer is
the extrinsic pathway. So
she falls, she scrapes her
knee, that's an external
injury. So the entire blood
vessel is being broken
and she's obviously bleeding.
So extrinsic, external.
Next, we're going to talk
about the feedback that is
important to make sure that
the hemostasis process does
not get out of control and
there's too much clotting.
So one really important way
is through proteins C and
S. These are also two
vitamin K-dependent proteins
that are synthesized in the
liver. They come together
and they form a complex with
thrombin and thrombomodulin,
and that then goes on to
inhibit factors 5 and 8.
Additionally, antithrombin
is a molecule that binds
and degrades thrombin, and
then it also inactivates
factors 9 and 10. So these
are really important not only
for the clotting cascade
but also for the effects
of warfarin on vitamin K
and heparin on antithrombin.
The very last step once the
endothelium is healed is
to get rid of the clot
and this is the process of
fibrinolysis. So we have
plasminogen which is converted
to plasmin and this is done
through a few different
molecules. The most likely
one you guys have heard
of is TPA. Other ones are
calicreon, streptokinase,
and urokinase. And then
plasmin is the molecule
that converts that cross
-linked fibrin mesh into soluble
fibrin and releases it
from the clot. So this is
the very final step that
gets rid of the clot and
we're now back to just a
normal healthy endothelium.
All right so we have another
question. What is
the main role of
antithrombin? I'll
give you guys a
little bit more time
with this one. If
you need more time
pause the video we're going
to go over the answer.
So the correct answer is to
bind and degrade thrombin.
So I think antithrombin
wants to stop thrombin and
then together they're going
to to inhibit clotting
factors from being activated.
Thrombin can no longer
activate factors, so we're going
to have decreased clotting.
So that's kind of the
feedback on the coagulation
cascade to make sure we
don't have too much clotting.
So next we're just going
to go over what happens
when there are some
issues with hemostasis.
In primary hemostasis,
you can have deficiencies
in the molecules and
in the receptors.
so one of those would be
von Willebrand disease this
is a deficiency of von
Willebrand factor so you're
not going to have that
initial platelet adhesion
if you don't have von
Willebrand factor to bind to
the collagen for those
platelet receptors to then
bind to so this could cause
increased bleeding and
then we have Bernard
Soulier syndrome which is a
deficiency of the GP1b
receptor so remember that is
the receptor on the platelet
that binds to the von
Willebrand factor. So you're
going to have a similar
problem as von Willebrand
disease, and you're not
going to be able to have
that platelet adhesion.
And then we have glansman
thrombocenia, which
is a deficiency of the
GP2B3A receptors. So
these are that last
receptor that's exposed on
the platelets once ADP
binds to its receptor.
This is going to decrease
aggregation. So platelets
might be able to initially
adhere to the collagen,
but they're not going
to be able to aggregate
as well, and they're not
going to be able to then
bind that fibrinogen and
make that fibrin mesh.
And then we also have disorders
of secondary hemostasis.
So I'm sure you guys have
all heard of hemophilia.
So this is when you have low
levels of clotting factors.
They're usually X-linked
recessive diseases. The
two most common ones are
hemophilia A and hemophilia B.
Hemophilia A is
when you have a lack
of factor 8, and
then hemophilia B
is when you have a
lack of factor 9.
So all of these
disorders are going to
decrease the body's
ability to adequately
form a clot, and
you're going to have
increased risk of bleeding
in these patients.
Okay, next we have a summary
of the different lab tests
we talked about and just
kind of what you should be
thinking when you see an
elevated result so first we
have decreased platelet number
so that's the definition
of thrombocytopenia
thrombocytopenia so with that you're
gonna get an increased
bleeding time that's one of
the tests on the lab results
you can look for and then
if you have a normal
platelet number but you have
increased bleeding time you
want to think about a platelet
dysfunction so you want
to think about those first
three under primary hemostasis
von Willebrand's disease,
glansman thrombocytopenia,
and the other one.
And then finally, we have
elevated PTINR or APTT.
So these, whenever you
see them elevated, you
want to think of the
coagulation cascade. So
it's going to have to do
with a clotting factor.
So when you have
just an elevated PTINR,
you want to think
of the extrinsic pathway.
And specifically,
you want to think of
a factor 7 deficiency.
When you have just an
elevated APTT, you want to
think of the intrinsic
pathway, and this is going
to be your hemophilia
disorder, so you could have
a decreased level of factors
8, 9, and then sometimes
11. And then when you
have an elevated PTINR
and APTT, it's both extrinsic
and intrinsic pathways,
you want to think of a
deficiency of vitamin K.
This will deplete
factors 2, 5, 8, and
10, and that has to
do with the extrinsic,
intrinsic, and the
common pathway.
So this will be helpful for you
guys to come back and review
later on.
Lastly, we have a brief overview
of the main antiplatelet
and anticoagulant drugs.
There's a lot more that's
going to be given to you in
another lecture. You guys
are going have specific farm
lectures this is here just
to help you start connecting
physiology to pharmacology
and how you're going to
use this information in the
future so our anti-platelets
these prevent primary
hemostasis so prevention of
that platelet plug formation
we have aspirin which we
know is a cox-1 inhibitor and
cox-1 is required to make
thromboxane in platelets so
you're going to have decreased
platelet aggregation.
And then you have
clopidogrel, which is a P2Y12
receptor inhibitor. It
binds and inactivates the
platelet, being able to
express the GP2B3A receptor.
So if that can't be
expressed, it's similar
to the glansman
thrombocypenia, and that's
going to be decrease
platelet aggregation.
And then we have anticoagulants.
So these are preventing
synthesis of certain
clotting factors. So this is
our secondary hemostasis.
We have heparin, which binds
to antithrombin 3, and it
increases that affinity for
factor 10a and thrombin,
and it's going to bind and
inactivate them. So decreased
levels of factor 10a and
thrombin. And remember,
heparin is monitored with APTT.
And then finally,
we have warfarin
that inhibits the enzyme that
activates vitamin K. So
you're going to have a lower
level of functional vitamin
K that can be used. So
you're not going to be able
to make as many of the vitamin
K dependent factors. So
those are 2, 7, 9, and 10.
And then also protein C and
protein S are also vitamin
K dependent, and that is
monitored with APT and INR.
And then lastly, we have
one more question. So a
50-year-old man comes
into the ED complaining of
black stools for the past
week. When you ask about
his diet, he tells you
that he is a very picky
eater and eats a lot
of cereal, grains, and
potatoes. He does not eat
much of meat, fruits, or
vegetables. You think
that he may have a vitamin
deficiency that is making
him bleed. Which of the
following has been depleted
due to his poor diet?
All right, we're going
to go over the answer.
So the factors that are
going to be depleted are
factors two and seven. So
he has a poor diet. You
think he has a vitamin
deficiency. That vitamin
deficiency you're thinking
of is vitamin K. So
then you're looking to see
what is vitamin K dependent,
and that's going to be
factors 2, 7, 9, and
10, as well as protein C
and protein F. So those
are really big ones that
you guys want to make sure
you know, all the vitamin
K dependent factors.
All right, so in summary, I
want you guys to think big
picture first and then try
to add in all the small
details. If you guys really
know this outline, it's
going to help. So start from
here and then see if you
can outline it from this
general outline with more
specific details of like
the receptors involved the
clotting factors involved and
like what happens when there's
dysfunction or like not
enough of one thing so we
have an injury to the
endothelium we start with primary
hemostasis so that's all
about platelets you want
to remember adhesion activation
aggregation the three
a's those are all to form
the initial platelet plug
then we have secondary hemostasis
this is the coagulation
cascade with all the
different clotting factors.
Intrinsic, you
want to remember,
is triggered by
something internal.
Extrinsic is triggered
by external injury that
causes bleeding. And
then both of them come
together in the common
pathway that's going to
stabilize that fibrin
mesh. And then finally,
you have fibrinolysis
that clears the fibrin
away and leaves you with
a healed endothelium.
So know this outline and
then just be able to name
the specific things I
pointed out, and you guys are
all going to do amazing
here are some resources
i used also i know there's
a lot of good summary
videos for like boards
and beyond and i think con
academy so you guys can look
at those it's really just
repetition you kind of
gotta draw it out yourself
let it sink in quiz yourself
questions are the best
way to do it and then here
is the lecture feedback
form so if you guys could
fill this out it'd be
really helpful to know
what you liked and what you
didn't like. Please feel
free to email me if you
have any specific questions
or if you see me on campus
feel free to stop me and
best of luck studying.